this is where I belong y'all right here
I am with my kind I smell alcohol and
weed I know I'm in the right area I'm in
rare form tonight we're fitting to turn
up I started drinking at noon baby we
showed up like hello
you never know what I'm gonna get with
you ain't that the best I'm just I'm
just fired up man I think I feel like
I've never been to one it's my third one
I'm still like man the Jitters don't get
old I'm singing on on a big National
platform again I know I take all that
real serious you know what I'm saying
it's a big deal dude when you get out
there on that stage and you're singing
to a crowd you had a crowd full of your
peers out there oh man it's gonna be
hard stapleton's sitting right in front
of me out there no matter how good I
sing I'm gonna think I suck
are you making eye contact no I can't
look at Stapleton while I'm singing
absolutely not I would man I'm petrified
well how do you act yeah cause what if
they fake it and they give me the
and it just hurts me forever you took us
to church last month what do we have in
store for this special guest appearance
performance you got going on here for us
tonight I think I feel like I'm gonna
take the world to a real intimate
meeting yeah I feel like sometimes you
take the show to the people and
sometimes you bring the people to the
show and tonight I want to feel like
we're all sitting around a campfire and
having a conversation I love that you
know a little River has it okay I know
you're going on tour with Lainey Wilson
I just think y'all would make the
perfect pairing up there on that stage
for tonight I do too man wouldn't that
be awesome if Lanny Wilson was my
special guest wouldn't it yeah that's
crazy man I mean I should ask her I'll
ask her but tell her yeah see if you
could put that together you all get
credit for it
well you do have a special documentary
coming out later this month I'm so
excited it's coming out May 30th it's
going to be on Hulu it's an ABC News Doc
it's about my life it's 90 minutes I
only watched the two-minute teaser and I
cried like a baby what are we going
real jelly roll man you're just going to
kind of see all the stories that I've
been telling you're going to get to see
and that's what's cool it's going to
really make an understanding because you
know everybody kind of familiar with the
story now but now we get to show it yeah
yeah it's always great to have your
presence on a
fun man I feel like I'm feeling Michael
Jackson moon slide out of here y'all I'm
from the moonwalk hit one of them right
there baby I'm getting up out of here
yeah you look at them are you talking
about the suit yeah
too baby it's gonna be the most
underestimated part of the fit
foreign